Captain Marvel is flying into theaters
in March 2019 and we have so many
questions that we can't wait to get
answered here are some of the hottest
fan theories that you need to know
before you see the latest movie from MCU
I'm gonna end it
what do you know for sure the Internet
is buzzing with any details we can get
about the new Captain Marvel movie and
the Internet has dissected them into the
tiniest details here's what we know so
far about Captain Marvel at some point
Carol Danvers was a fighter pilot
it appears that she crashes and nearly
dies then she meets up with a young Nick
Fury the two become partners to stop an
alien invasion did you have funny enough
Captain Marvel isn't fully human herself
and we know this because her blood is
blue it soon revealed that she is part
Kree if you remember from the guardians
of the galaxy movies the Kree are a
fierce warrior race we don't know
whether Captain Marvel was born Kree or
if she becomes Korea through some mad
scientist process earth is being invaded
by scroll scroll are an evil alien race
that can disguise themselves as human
that's why you see Captain Marvel punch
an old lady on the train the sweet old
grandma is actually a scroll Carol
Danvers also has some memory issues she
has a few memories from a past life on
earth but she can't piece it together
thanks to samuel l.jackson we also know
that Captain Marvel is possibly the
strongest hero in the entire MCU and she
has the ability to time travel we also
know that some familiar MCU faces are
making an appearance to acree from the
guardians of the galaxy franchise are
back Ronan the accuser is played by Lee
pace to refresh your memory
Ronan with Santos's Ally man in the
first guardians movie he went after the
orb for Thanos in exchange for the
decimation of Xander
but he kept the orbs infinity stone for
himself and was defeated by star-lord
carafes the pursuer is played by Jamin
Honsou he is an officer under Ronan's
command in Captain Marvel these two Kree
will be members of the Star Force along
with Carol Danvers the other familiar
face is Agent Coulson fans Berg gutted
he met his end by Loki in the first
adventures but he comes back as a
younger version of himself in Captain
Marvel Nick Fury's eye one of Nick
Fury's defining characteristics is his
eyepatch he is missing an eye and this
makes him look super tough but we don't
know how Fury lost his eye if you watch
to the Captain Marvel trailers you
probably noticed something huge young
Nick Fury has both of his eyes I'm just
supposed to take your word for that
we know this movie takes place a few
years before the first Iron Man movie
sometime between these two films he lost
his eye it's been pretty much confirmed
that he loses his eye in this film
seriously what is with Marvel and eyes
just look at Thor but how will it happen
one theory has to do with Captain
Marvel's cat goose in the second trailer
Fury is seen going all gaga for his
kitty it would be hilarious if tough
fury lost his eye to something as cuddly
as a cat in the comics Nick Fury lost
his eye in world war two but considering
Captain Marvel takes place 50 years
later that doesn't make sense for the
movie Nick Fury is apparently going to
double-cross his boss
Talos and Talos could be responsible for
the loss of his eye also what if it's
Captain Marvel that causes it in Captain
America the Winter Soldier theory says
that the last time he trusted someone it
cost him and I that sounds like it's
going to be something way more intense
than just fighting the scroll what do
you think is responsible for taking Nick
Fury's eye Captain Marvel is a scroll in
the trailers we see Captain Marvel
undergoing some sort of brain procedure
it looks super painful and terrifying
but we don't have any idea what this
means was this when she was rescued by
the Kree and got powers did someone
implant false memories of life on earth
into her brain or did she willingly
undergo this procedure to find her
missing memories some fans think that
there is another explanation they think
that Captain Marvel might be a scroll in
disguise you think I am we know that
scroll can shape-shift to look like any
other species here's a thought maybe
Captain Marvel doesn't know who she
really is the scroll wants her to find
out the truth so she'll help them she
could be a scroll who was brainwashed by
the Kree some people think that Nick
fury is going to figure out that she is
a scroll in disguise they may have a
showdown okay we know this may seem like
a stretch if she is a scroll that would
definitely make her even more powerful
the ability to look like anyone else
would come in handy for the adventures
but even if she is a scroll this doesn't
mean that she's evil she could be
fighting to take down her own people it
would also explain how she is able to
easily identify the old woman scroll on
the train captain Marvel's mom Peter
Quill's dad is evil in guardians of the
galaxy to Tony Stark and his dad didn't
have a great relationship
Odin lies to his sons about having
another kid who is super evil in Thor
Ragnarok and let's not forget that
Thanos adopted Gamora after wiping out
her planet then he sacrificed her for
the soul stone Marvel is changing things
up with a female superhero in a starring
role so what if they change things up to
include some mommy issues actress
Annette Bening is in the Captain Marvel
trailers she says that the Kree saved
Carole's life the day it nearly ended
they gave her superpowers and trained
her to become a warrior hero
she says they made her one of them there
are a couple of possibilities here one
is that you can become Kree even if
you're born another race that could be
why Ronan and Korath don't look human
the other possibility is that Carole was
always Kree
but was raised human on earth a popular
theory is that an S biddings character
will turn out to be Carole's mom was she
human that turned Kree does Carrol have
a human father we have so many questions
also the Kree aren't exactly good in the
Guardians movies it's possible that
benning's character turns out to be a
villain a parent that turns out to be
bad isn't exactly new territory for the
MCU Thanos warning there are a lot of
theories about captain Marvel's role in
Avengers endgame many people think that
she is the only one strong enough to
defeat Thanos
and wield the Infinity Gauntlet but we
are focusing on her role in Captain
Marvel Captain Marvel is obviously an
important superhero but she is missing
from all of the other alien
visions in the MCU why does Nick Fury
decide to call on her at the end of
infinity Wars one theory suggests that
she actually warned fury about Thanos
his plan
we know that she has the ability to time
travel she might know exactly what they
a knows plan to do Nick Fury contacts
her own a super old pager but Shield has
a really advanced technology it sure
looks like fury knew exactly what to do
when half the universe started getting
vaporized this could explain why he was
carrying this super old pager on him
there's a good chance that fury knew
exactly what was going to happen
Captain Marvel might be the one who
warned him then she told him to page her
when it goes down the cat when the
closer for Captain Marvel dropped there
was one other character featured a cute
orange cat was seen in one corner of the
poster live at a copy in the poster
unless it is really important to the pot
here's what we know about the cat in the
movies his name is goose but in the
comics Carroll's cat is named chili
after Chewbacca from Star Wars
in the comics Chewie is no ordinary cat
he is an alien called a Fleur Caen clerk
ins look a lot like cats but they are
way weirder they actually lay hundreds
of eggs at a time we've already talked
about how funny would be if Nick Fury
lost his eye to a cat of course he would
trust a cute kitty and fury does have
scars that looked like claw marks if
this is the case goose may just be
trying to protect his owner so what if
goose isn't a good kitty cat
what if goose is a scroll that would be
a perfect way to get insider information
on Captain Marvel seconds also have a
really strange power inside of each of
them is a dimension to another dimension
or timeline it's possible that goose
exists in a completely alternate
timeline from the rest of the MCU if
that's the case goose may save the
entire universe that leads us to our
next theory Captain Marvel is trapped in
the quantum realm
you probably remember the quantum realm
from the ant-man movie this is another
dimension where time and space are a
revelant
we know the quantum realm is going to be
important in both Captain Marvel and
Avengers endgame in the comics the
heroes who get snapped out of existence
end up in the soul Realm
is outsmarted and the time stone is used
to turn back time to 24 hours before
then Oh snaps his fingers there are a
couple of characters who are not part of
MCU that play a crucial role in the
comics a lot of people think that
Captain Marvel is going to be the one
who takes on this role she already has
the ability to time travel the leading
theory is that the rest of the Avengers
are trapped in the quantum realm but
what if Captain Marvel is already
trapped there that would explain why she
hasn't been around for all the other MCU
movies
if goose has a whole other dimension
inside him it could turn out to be the
quantum realm goose and Captain Marvel
might exist outside this reality and we
know that ant-man was able to escape
from it that means Captain Marvel can -
in the comics Captain Marvel yields the
reality stone this would allow her to
reconstruct reality without Thanos
everyone would come back or maybe she
just frees everyone from inside her cat
wouldn't it be awesome if the cat is the
key to saving the universe we can't wait
to find out more about the quantum realm
Doctor Strange Captain Marvel takes
place about a decade before the first
iron man but that doesn't mean that we
can't have a crossover from another
superhero there is one other MCU hero
who can travel through time that is none
other than Doctor Strange
he has also visited other dimensions in
infinity Wars Doctor Strange calculated
all the possibilities for the Avengers
to be successful he saw only one
possible outcome and that required
Thanos to succeed in snapping half the
population out of existence there is a
theory that he didn't just do some fancy
calculations he might have actually time
traveled if he sees that Captain Marvel
is the key to beating Thanos he would
need to warn someone right well what if
he went and warned Captain Marvel
herself he could travel back to the
early 1990s and meet her he could also
travel to tell Nick Fury to summon
captain marvel at just the right time we
think it would be awesome if Doctor
Strange showed up in Captain Marvel if
he does Marvel is doing a great job at
keeping it under wraps but they've kept
bigger secrets from their fans before to
time-traveling superheroes are going to
they come in handy especially in in game
we are so excited about Captain Marvel
it premieres on March 8th 2019 so which
of these fan theories do you think are
correct what else do you think will
happen in the new movie let us know in
the comments those are some of the most
interesting theories about Captain
Marvel form or MCU news hit that
subscribe button thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]